you did handle it better you were right
believe it or not and
I actually was not that surprised on it
because uh it's a lot of what I talk
about on this show uh the Santa Scott
Bill Maher to agree on a lot of stuff
here they are talking about uh taking
out the Deep State and all of the
institutions that have become so erotic
it doesn't work but that's driven by
ideology so it's not just we're having
just a philosophical debate I think woke
ideology is corrupted institutions I
think it's corrupted things like the CDC
with how they handled a covid with the
nonsense that they did so it's a broader
issue than just a philosophical fight
you keep wanting to get back to that and
I don't blame you because you're right
we're on the same page there and I think
it's it's unfair what they did to you
because you did handle it better
you did handle it better you were right
you were like let's target the people
protect the people who are most
vulnerable and everybody else can go on
with their lives a little better you
open schools sooner and a lot of the
stuff that's come in the information we
have after now we've had a few years to
look at it you were more right
and they won't give you credit for that
the New York credit for me though it's
not about credit for me okay but about
them admitting that they were wrong
because they are setting us up if this
happened again they would repeat the
same Playbook all over again and if we
don't have accountability that's what's
going to happen so I'll bring
accountability so it never happens in
our country again I said the New York
Times did such a Despicable hit piece on
you that I saw because
I forget what the lead headline was but
it was basically Ron descent is
up to the pandemic and then like at the
very end it says Florida's death rate
overall was better than the national
average now if you're going to do an
article if you're going to do an article
about Florida and the pandemic shouldn't
that be the lead shouldn't that be the I
mean we're the number one state for in
migration I mean if we did so bad people
would have been leaving Florida people
are coming Wells moving into the state
our economy's done better than any other
large State and education we're now
ranked I think in the top five on most
metrics in education now that wasn't
true when I was a kid growing up in
Florida so we we did it right but what
we did is we understood you can't stop
society because of one respiratory virus
look I know that you guys know all that
stuff right you know that DeSantis was
great on coven you know that there's
every reason to believe that he would
rain hell down on the agencies in the
CDC and the NIH and all of those things
and he got if he got into office because
he has the track record of actually
doing what he says the reason I wanted
to show you that part specifically was
because Bill Maher was in complete
agreement with him that he was great on
covid so think about how the how
politics may make strange bedfellows out
of people you've got Donald Trump
constantly lying it is simply a lie and
we just all have to acknowledge it and
you can say it's a good tactical thing
and lying is okay in the ends justify
the means and all that but Donald Trump
every day lying about DeSantis and kovid
and mandates and lockdowns and all of
those things and all his surrogates do
the doing the exact same thing and here
you have Lefty liberal Bill Maher who
will I sadly think never vote for a
republican will never vote for DeSantis
but he at least has the balls to tell
the truth right like they did not give
you the credit you deserve they lie
about you
foreign